-Guys, it's Thursday. You wanna do a little "Roses and Thorns"?
-Oh, yeah. -Yeah. Let's go around the room.
Check in. I'll go first.
My rose is I ordered
a brand-new flat-screen TV for the Super Bowl.
-Oh. -Yeah.
-My thorn is it was being delivered
by that Chinese balloon.
-Ohh. -Yeah.
Higgins, do you have a rose and a thorn?
-Oh, my God. Do I ever.
I scored tickets to see Beyoncé in concert.
-Oh! You -- That's fantastic! What's -- What's the thorn?
-The thorn is my children
will no longer be able to attend college.
-Oh, that's terrible. That's sad.
Uh, Mark, how about you, bud?
-Yeah, uh, my rose is, at lunch today
I got an extra Chicken McNugget in my order.
-Oh, that's good! That's -- That's lucky.
That's good. What's the thorn?
-My thorn is, I was eating at Chipotle.
-Ohh. -I gotcha.
James, you want to finish us off here?
-Yeah.
My rose is my wife booked a dinner reservation
for Valentine's Day.
-Ohh! That's good. I like that. What's the thorn?
-My thorn is, it's with our pool boy, Geraldo.
-Maybe we shouldn't do "Roses and Thorns."
We'll be right back with "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Come on back.